E aí
[Música]
hoje eu vou contar para vocês três
situações da minha vida que eu tomei
decisões erradas e como é que isso
reflete na minha vida a primeira delas
foi na época da faculdade quando eu fui
abrir a minha conta universitária só que
com a conta universitária vem o cartão
de crédito e minha mãe na hora me falou
Sara você não tem a menor condição de
ter um cartão de crédito agora você não
tem renda os juros são altíssimos é
muito arriscado o cheque especial é
arriscado e para ser bem sincera eu não
tinha condição financeira nenhuma de dar
aquele passo mesmo
é só que eu fui lá e fiz o cartão de
crédito
a segunda dela situação é meados de 2013
quando eu tinha 22 anos e eu traí o meu
namorado da época eu já estava num
relacionamento que não fazia sentido eu
tava triste as diferenças já estavam
tomando uma proporção muito grande e eu
invés de eu ter uma conversa sincera
expor meus sentimentos eu decidi traí
meu namorado e aí um ou dois dias depois
eu acabei terminando
e a terceira situação foi quando eu tava
tirando carteira e o meu exame de
direção foi marcado para o dia quatro de
janeiro e eu viajei no Réveillon fui pra
praia com os meus amigos festas curtição
e a minha carona iria voltar no dia três
é só que tinha uma outra carona que
voltaria no dia sete de Janeiro
e eu queria muito ficar
o que eu fiz esse sim continuei lá
cancelei a carona do dia três e voltei
no dia sete e perdi o meu exame de
direção
Ah e por que que eu tô contando isso
para vocês porque embora pareça as
decisões corriqueiras da vida de uma
jovem todas essas decisões tiveram um
impacto muito grande na minha vida e eu
vou contar para vocês agora quais foram
esses impactos e como eu me senti nesses
momentos
e No primeiro caso do cartão de crédito
óbvio que isso virou uma bola de neve
primeiro mês eu não tinha dinheiro para
pagar no segundo juntou com juros no
terceiro juros mas uma bola de neve foi
se arrastando por meses e meses por anos
o meu nome ficou sujo e eu morava com a
minha mãe na época a minha mãe que falou
para eu não fazer o cartão de crédito e
começou a chegar as cartas de cobrança e
como que eu explicava isso para ela e aí
eu tive que mentir e eu mente muitas
vezes para minha mãe muitas vezes porque
se arrastou se arrastou por anos
não faz isso não me faz uma pessoa
mentirosa
e no segundo caso que eu contei para
vocês onde eu traí meu namorado eu não
tinha a menor ideia do que eu tinha
feito ele acabou descobrindo e passou
algum tempo ele me questionou eu neguei
de primeira passou um tempo eu acabei
contando que eu tinha realmente feito
isso mas mesmo assim eu não tinha ideia
do que eu estava fazendo do que eu tinha
feito e só depois de um ano onde ele me
procurou novamente
me contou tudo o que tinha acontecido na
vida dele nesse período que ele tinha
ficado muito triste que ele tinha se
questionado que ele tinha pensado que
era uma coisa com ele que ele tinha
ficado depressivo Foi aí que eu comecei
a entender o tanto que eu tinha sido
egoísta
e se não me faz uma pessoa egoísta
é o terceiro caso onde o priorizei o
lazer os meus amigos curtição e foi
extremamente inconsequente e não fiz o
meu exame de direção e sete anos depois
hoje eu não tenho carteira de motorista
até hoje fazer isso não me faz uma
pessoa inconsequente
e eu poderia ficar aqui narrando mais
milhões de outras vezes que eu tomei
decisões erradas até outros que eu tomei
decisões certas mas nenhum desses dois
momentos pontuais me definem Nem os
piores e nem os melhores
é e como é que eu consegui ter essa
clareza
é porque eu me perdoei e eu me perdoo
diariamente
É porque quando eu tomei essas decisões
eu não me conhecia Como Eu me conheço
hoje
É porque todas essas decisões me
Trouxeram até aqui até hoje até agora e
eu tenho muito orgulho da mulher que eu
sou e que eu busco ser todos os dias
e eu acho que a virada da chave está
muito aí da gente ir se perdoando
deixando para trás tudo aquilo que não
condiz mais com quem a gente é com quem
a gente quer ser é necessário praticar o
auto perdão
a entender que as suas piores decisões
não te definem te ajudando Inclusive a
entender então quê que te define quem é
você qual o seu valor Quais são os seus
valores Qual o seu caráter e isso sim
está diretamente relacionado a tomar
melhores decisões
e eu queria deixar para vocês quatro
dicas para tomar melhores decisões a
primeira delas a gente acabou de falar
as suas piores decisões não te define
bom então se perdoe e siga a segunda é
se conheça
se conecte com a sua essência
em todas essas vezes que eu narrei para
vocês essas decisões erradas que eu
tomei eu não tinha a menor ideia quem eu
era qual era o meu valor qual era o meu
caráter eu agi por impulso eu me
perguntava
é o que eu queria fazer eu me conectava
com quem eu era com a minha essência
bom então se conheça Pratique o
autoconhecimento e eu uso dizer que
todas as perguntas que você tem as
respostas estão dentro de você
e a terceira dica é diferencie as coisas
que você pode mudar daquelas que você
não pode mudar
Ah e não fica gastando muita energia com
aquelas que você não pode mudar você não
tem nada controle nenhum sobre elas
Oi e a quarta e última dica é seja
sincero com você com os outros com todas
as pessoas que estão diretamente
relacionadas aquela tomada de decisão
porque assim todas as decisões vão estar
alinhadas com a verdade e a verdade é
uma só eu não precisa mais ficar
enrolando e falando mais nada
a entender
o que você não é as suas piores decisões
é muito importante
é mas queira vá de encontro a tomar
melhores decisões assuma o controle da
sua vida
se você é protagonista dela você é
responsável por ela você sempre vai ter
opção diante das coisas que acontecem
e você não vai controlar as coisas que
acontecem com você mas definitivamente
você escolhe como você reage a tudo que
te acontece
bom obrigada